complètent le 28 décembre il ya bientôt
deux ans
on dormait tous à la maison moi et mes
deux filles mon fils n'était pas là et
en fait on a eu un incendie et à
14h45 le matin en fait jacques arrivée
ma fille océane qui à l'époque avait 14
ans
en fait il a aboyé une première fois ll
a rouspété et puis elle lui a dit ott et
toi qu'est le cirque couché en fait il a
grimpé carrément sur elle et il l'a
griffée par tous comme ça pour qu'elle
se réveille parce qu'en fait l'incendié
était vraiment déclaré on a tout perdu
en fait dans n'a pas dans l'appartement
et en du coup ma fille s'est levé avec
lui et et elle s'est en fait elle a vu
des lumières donc elle s'est avancée
vers le couloir vers la lumière est là
la vue qu'en fait il y avait le feu au
salon et moi ma chambre était de l'autre
côté en fait donc du coup elle
m'appelait mais moi j'étais dans le
sommeil profond et on peut s'attendre
douala on était en j'étais vraiment le
sommeil profond et du coup elle a dû
traverser le salon en flammes pour venir
me réveiller et sa soeur nous a rejoints
j'aurais ouvert on a ouvert la porte
d'entrée et on est sortis quoi mais
dites-moi l'alarmé incendie n'a pas
marché nous sommes en fait si elle avait
fonctionné a pas fonctionné elle n'a pas
fonctionné alors qu'elle avait été vu au
mois d'octobre à et nous ça nous
arrivait le 28 décembre en tout cas il a
quatre ans je crois votre jack 6 ans la
main six ans maintenant elle à l'époque
il y avait quatre c'est arrivé il avait
80 il avait 4 ans maintenant c'est
dingue ce et puis je crois qu si vous
avez vécu grâce à ce chien non seulement
il a sauvé toute la famille de l'
incendie il est déjà merveilleux
évidemment et pour ça on les aime encore
plus et je crois qu'il ya eu un très
très bel élan de solidarité autour de
vous je crois oui beaucoup la famille
les amis des inconnus aussi qui nous ont
aidés et après ça a été très compliqué
mais maintenant on est bien on est dans
un nouvel appartement jack va mieux
aussi depuis à peu près six mois parce
qu'il avait développé le syndrome
l'attachement en fait il supportait pas
de sel mais il n'est pas du trophée
c'était celle quoi et puis partout où il
pleuvrait la boyer donc du coup on
pouvait plus du tout le laisser seul
après l'incendié quoi est là depuis six
mois six mois ça va ça va un peu mieux
on a notre logement depuis juin l'année
dernière ce qui a eu un confinement donc
sûre on n'a pas eu une autre logement
tout de suite on était dans un logement
en attente
et déjà qu'il était un héros comme ça
j'espère qu'il a obtenu une récompense
va pas du tout on nous avait dit qu'il
aurait une récompense bon c'est en fait
il n'y a rien eu de fait je pense c'est
parce qu'il ya eu coded juste derrière
et du fou de dallas il aurait pas une
surprise celui
que vous croyez pas que je vais
peut-être
oublié ont félicité jack mais nous ici à
oif ouf nous avons une belle récompense
pour votre chien jha qui a sauvé toute
la famille et vous même il vous a rendu
heureux bien sûr
une médiane
[Applaudissements]
d'y aller c
voyez bien une vraie mais d'allemagne et
leur chef jack au nom du président de la
république française
de tous les bruits de france au nom de
toute la police au nom de tous les
connards qui met mal les alarmes
on est très heureux de récompenser jack
[Applaudissements]
si beaucoup c'était moi j'adore ce genre
d'histoire c'est tellement émouvant
l'amour est plus fort que la technique
puisque le chien lui était beaucoup plus
fiable oui